أعتقد أن ما نسمعه من
الرئيس التركي هنا من خلال
المتحدث باسم حزبه يصل إلى جوهر
هذا وهو أنه لا يوجد ما يكفي في هذا
البيان حتى الآن بحيث يقف حقًا
أمام التدقيق ، فأنت تعلم ما نسمعه
عن الزعيم التركي  هو حديث
دبلوماسي حقًا لأنه لا يوجد ما يكفي
في كل ما يقول إننا
سنواصل تسليط الضوء على هذه القضية بحيث لا
ينبغي لأحد أن يشك في أن تركيا ستدفع
تحقيقها إلى الأمام ، لكنها تقول إن
البيان يقول إنهم
لن يتسرعوا  لإلقاء اللوم على
شخص معين ، لكنهم
لن يتركوا هذا يذبل في
الظلام والظلام المحيط
بهذا هو المكان الذي توجد فيه هيئة Jamarcus Rajas
بالضبط كيف حدث هذا الموقف بالضبط.
يتحدث البيان السعودي عن
التعاون مع المسؤولين الأتراك
بأن  تم إرسال الصوت في السادس من أكتوبر
بعد 4 أيام من اختفاء كاتاشي ،
أرسلوا فريق التحقيق الخاص بهم هنا
إلى اسطنبول ولكن الحقائق على الأرض
تتحدث بشكل كبير  r بصوت عالٍ أكثر من تلك
الكلمات الواردة في البيان السعودي مدفونة
في ليلة وضحاها في مذيعة الأخبار الليلية التي تم
بثها في تمام الساعة 1
صباحًا بتوقيت السعودية ، كانت الحقائق على
الأرض هي أنه إذا كان ذلك عندما
وصل هؤلاء المحققون السعوديون في
6 صباحًا.  في أكتوبر / تشرين الأول ، لم
يسمح هؤلاء
المحققون السعوديون للمحققين الأتراك بالدخول إلى
القنصلية إلا في الخامس عشر من أكتوبر
، وعندما فعلوا ذلك ، تم
رسم القنصلية من الداخل ، ومع ذلك لا
تزال هناك معلومات حول
مكان وجود جمال كوشير.  أو
أي تفاصيل حول ذلك
وذاك بالطبع ستكون ذات أهمية كبيرة
لعائلته وأولئك الذين يحبونه